>> Hi I'm Peter Galison. How are you YouTube?
And I'm a professor of Science and Physics
at Harvard. I've been at the World Economics
Forum and quite impressed with the seriousness
with which some of the environmental issues
have been discussed. But as for 2009, I would
say I think the environment will lose out
to the economy, but I think the hope for 2009
is that a longer term, five year say scope,
would be considered because if we're going
to change things with respect to global warming,
it's not going to be over the next six months.
It's going to have to be over the next five
years with respect to the way we think of
alternative generation power. The way we think
of the efficiency of cars. The way we think
of some fundamental issues that face us in
trying to reduce the carbon levels into the
environment. Thanks.